all right everybody this is ross so
in today's video i thought i would take
you guys around the yard
and show you guys different trees
different fruiting plants
that i have whether that's the grape
vines some of the bushes that might be
growing some of these fruit trees like
these are cherries
and apples and pears and persimmons all
the different things that
i grow here on this property i thought i
would touch on pruning
each individual one we're not going to
get to all of them but what i want to
really go over
is things like form what the trees look
like kind of things you shouldn't do
this is all going to be about winter
pruning by the way
and there's really two different types
of pruning i guess you could really
narrow it down
to winter pruning and summer pruning and
i would actually argue
for the majority of the species that you
guys can grow
in a more temperate climate like my own
in the philadelphia area
i would say you're probably your best
bet is actually to do some summer
pruning
and to really stay on top of that that's
going to really help with a lot of us
throughout the country that have disease
pressure maybe you guys have a lot of
pest pressure
it's going to really keep these trees in
a state of
uh size control for us that are backyard
growers
and it's also gonna really help with uh
getting ourselves a
good fruit set every year when we do a
lot of winter pruning
and you know it's not technically i
guess really the winter right now
or we're approaching the spring very
quickly there are some trees on my
property that have broken bud
and yeah you could argue that i guess
it's not really the wintertime at that
point anymore but
certainly if you're doing pruning when
the tree is still semi-dormant or
dormant you're gonna then contribute
towards the following season or during
the growing season
having a lot of growth that's kind of
the tree's natural response we change
the hormones within the tree actually
when we do our pruning
we are directly impacting the hormones
in these trees and in these fruiting
plants
so that's really what you need i think
to take that perspective going into all
of this
is what exactly is it that we're doing
we're really just changing the hormones
and by doing this in the winter
we're changing the hormones in a way
that is promoting growth
promoting vigor for the next season
and for a lot of us that might not be
something we really want
in the summer instead on a lot of these
fruiting plants
we actually are going to be promoting
flour
and producing budwood or
spurs or wood that actually has
flowers or fruit buds on it so
that's really key there i think that
little distinction there in terms of
the difference now these are cherries
these are on semi dwarf
stock and what i really don't like about
these trees after i've
been pruning them for a number of years
you know i didn't know all the things i
i know today when i first started as i
learned
i got more knowledge and i've learned
from my mistakes and i'll tell you that
these cherry trees have a pretty good
form
but only in this area of the tree
ideally this area here should be a
couple feet
lower and that you can see all this
really good branching up in here
it's really forming a nice dense canopy
after
years of finally pruning them back a bit
harder than i um
would have really anticipated from the
beginning
in the winter time they then start to
put out all these different shoots
all these different growth points that
then form really the canopy i've wanted
and a big recommendation for anyone in
the in a backyard
environment is that we want to prune
them when you first get them as a whiff
right you're just starting out maybe you
guys are not at this point yet
is you want to prune them at your knee
and that's going to create the branching
down below but
sometimes you don't get exactly all the
branching that you want it doesn't
branch out
as much as you need like this tree here
i did exactly that
and it only put out two different
branches maybe three different branches
and for me that's just not enough
because we really want this
big dense canopy a lot lower and you can
see as i get higher up on the tree
there's
one two three four maybe even five
you know main scaffolds to this tree
i'm gonna zoom in bring you guys
closer these main scaffolds that i'm i'm
looking at here are really what are
going to produce the main
fruit from you know going forward so if
i have more of these scaffolds
and i have them in a higher quantity but
i have them at a lower point
we're gonna be better off with size
control i mean that's a really big point
i think
you know you've got the trunk down here
and then it forks off and you could say
that oh well these are scaffolds
but really technically as we go up
higher you could even make an argument
that these four branches here
are really the main scaffolds and then
from there of course we get this
diverse dense canopy here with all the
fruit buds on it and you can see
you know this is kind of a great time to
do the pruning because you can very
clearly see what's a fruit bud and
what's a knot and you know
what's it not but you know this is
obviously a fruit bud if you can see
all those different buds there in a
cluster now these are cherries and every
fruiting plant unfortunately you're
going to have to learn
how exactly they behave what they look
like but
one of the most surefire ways to know
what is a flower cluster what will be
actually a fruit is just to wait until
they start to break bud
now that tree obviously hasn't just yet
i'm really quite surprised even though
technically i would say around early to
mid march we do
start to see bud break here i'm actually
quite surprised to see it as early as we
have this year
simply just because of the the very cold
um weather we've been having and it just
turned warm
and all it really took was that warm
snap of weather
to really get these trees breaking bud
now i'll show you
this was one area here that i really
like to talk about is actually the
espalier for a home gardener
the asparagus just can't be beat in my
opinion i think it's beautiful
it functions in so many different ways
and it also produces a ton of fruit now
these peach trees have been here i think
for six or seven
this might be their seventh year i'm not
i don't remember exactly how many years
it's been
but the point is is that they really
have a beautiful
uh form to them and that they have the
arms going out and
it's not perfect you know there's some
gaps in here and actually
i had to cut out a couple scaffolds
not a couple scaffolds a couple arms on
the cordons here it's supposed to be
three tiers right
there's a tier down here there's a tear
in the middle and there's a tier at the
top
unfortunately if you don't do this
really uh
the best way and the right way from the
beginning and you kind of make a few
maybe you make a few mistakes and you
don't go back and correct it
you could actually have a situation like
myself where
you actually had to cut out some of the
arms and i cut them out because the wood
was dead
and the reason why the wood was dead is
because this growth up here
or maybe even this growth down here is
then shading
out that growth and anything that gets
shaded in let's say the center or the
bottom of the tree
is going to just die it's just the tree
is not going to want to put the energy
in to support that anymore
so it's going to be gone and really the
main pruning i've done
not just on these but the trees we can
you know we just looked at those cherry
trees i really just came in here and
really
thinned out some of that density i don't
want a lot of this dense wood we came in
here
obviously we looked at here actually is
some branching that i missed
that's dead or diseased or damaged in
some way that's obviously going to come
out
but really i think at this point once
you get your tree somewhat established
after we
you know we cut it back at the knee we
get the form that we want let's say
maybe it's in this style here well we're
not going to cut it back
at the knee and we're going to let the
single stem whip grow all the way to the
top of the wire
and then we're going to cut it and then
we're going to let it branch out
and tie those main branches down to that
wire
but regardless of how you're doing this
um once you have this really set up
i think the winter pruning is really
just for opening up the center a bit
more
if you have a lot of branching
especially up here towards the top
that's really dense and thick
we got to remove some of that i took out
some really big cuts
and that was mostly it i got my saw and
i made bigger cuts
that makes a bigger difference than just
coming in here and doing some very
fine detail pruning you can't
necessarily go
too hard with this because there's so
much fruit wood here
i mean all of this down here pretty much
at my head level
down has got fruit on it and it's uh
it's in huge abundance
so i wouldn't necessarily worry i know
some people
come into the winter pruning or the
pruning at this time of the year and
they think oh
i don't want to go too hard with my
pruning because i'm going to lose all my
fruit
well when your tree is established
you're going to have more fruit than you
know what to do with
so i wouldn't think about it like that i
would really think about it in terms of
well when i make this cut how is the
tree going to respond
in terms of growth and if you have a lot
of growth let's say at the top
and you're just doing some thinning it's
not going to be a big deal because
well you've already got branches that
have that dominance
right the highest branches on the trees
have that apical dominance that's that
hormone
that i'm talking about if you make those
cuts you change those hormones
then now the tree then struggles to find
a difference
in dominance or maybe there's competing
branches
so for me that's all it really was i
came in here at the top i made a couple
cuts
took out some of the dead wood i'm still
seeing some dead wood
um you know i came over here at the top
took out some of those branches we even
just trimmed this back a little bit so
that this isn't encroaching too far
outwards away from the fence and uh
and that was mostly it i mean it's uh
it's really that simple what i should do
for the future and i could i guess
if i really wanted to is cut out
everything up here
and make just a cut right up in here
and i could really pay attention to in
the future is in the summer
keep doing my summer pruning if i don't
want to make these trees so tall
now these are almost 20 feet tall
you know it's certainly at least 15 so
if they're 15 feet tall and i'm saying
to myself i can't reach
some of the fruit up here i need a
ladder well
you know it is what it is i have to
either change my strategy or just deal
with it
so if you're somebody who doesn't want
to get on a ladder doesn't want to have
to deal with this
there's a lot of fruit up here maybe i
could leave it for the birds maybe i
could leave it for the animals or
whatnot but
you know in my experience it's probably
better and i wish i knew this from the
past as i probably
could have just made a cut all the way
across the top and just keep everything
nice and pruned as the summer progresses
don't let anything get away from you
and that controls the size and also
produces budwood for next year
it's not like i should say fruiting wood
for next year it's not like i'm gonna
lose out i mean all this stuff
down here on these lower tiers is bent
over got the nice angle to it it's
filled with fruits
filled with flowers i should say and
i'll be fine i don't really have to
worry too much
now we go over here to the grapes
it's a pretty different story i mean of
course we have our level of permanence
right we've got ourselves a trunk
we then put out some scaffolds we we
have that permanence that we can always
come back to
or build off of the grapevine's
quite similar and it really does depend
on how you want to do it but
i got myself my main trunk i have myself
my two arms along the wire
and then along the wire i have myself
the spurs
and along these spurs i just keep
cutting them back
to maybe one or two buds and every year
this the spurs get a little bit longer
a little bit taller and uh and that's it
with grapes you really do have to worry
about pruning them
too early simply because a lot of the
wood can
dry out and desiccate in the wintertime
so it's definitely advised
to wait until about now
kind of right before bud break so um my
apples are kind of a similar
story i mean this is a little bit
different though in in terms of
their dwarf they're very dwarf they're
not like the semi dwarves we looked at
with those cherries in the beginning you
know those cherries will get to maybe 15
feet
you know these peaches here will get to
about 30. these are standard sized trees
but these apples
you know some of them are on different
rootstock you can tell this guy over
here
is approaching a much taller height than
the rest of them
but for the most part in this high
density that i have them planted in
you really just want to be careful about
thinning them out not letting them get
too tall
keeping them a bit shorter i really do
believe that
the same principles can be said for
those cherries
and i made the same mistakes on these
apples where
we just didn't prune them hard enough in
the earlier years we really didn't bring
them back
to get the branching that we wanted at a
lower height
and they're a bit lanky because of it
and there's a few reasons for that
a lack of knowledge the location that
they're in but
some of these more lanky uh branches
here
the same thing could be said
in the summer and in the winter times
that we do a lot of pruning now we're
gonna get a lot of growth
next year however if i you know really
stay on top of my summer pruning
it's not out of the question where i can
keep these guys
to a very reasonable height very compact
and exactly what we want
now here's actually some
some younger espalier trees
that we have against the fence these are
plums
and we did also we did a really good job
this time around getting my plums to the
right
shape getting them bent down here along
the wire
they all have the right thing going on
here you can see we've got
the arms perfectly laid out
this guy here is going to probably
struggle a little bit to get some growth
this year
but for the most part i would say this
is the only only the weakest
arm of the trees these two trees here
we got it to the appropriate height and
then we chopped it off at that height as
soon as that whip
gets to the height that you want it then
starts to send out shoots
and of course we got one shoot on the
right
one shoot on the left we tie them down
to the wire
and then you have a very beautiful start
to uh an asparage
and i didn't prune these guys yet what's
nice about pruning plums
right now is that they just broke bud
and i can very clearly see
where the fruits are going to be i also
don't want to have too much
fruit on these trees they're very young
however i'm not going to be at this
location forever
and i probably will be taking these
standard plums with me
so um i'm going to let them fruit
probably as much as i can get out of
them
and then i'm going to take them dig them
up take them with me
and kind of worry about the overall
progression of the tree it's some later
year
but certainly i think these longer
shoots particularly the ones that don't
have a ton of fruit on them
um like this guy here and this guy here
usually the the more
lanky taller shoots don't have a ton of
fruit on them that's actually how the
hormones work
is that when we have branches that are
more straight up in the air
they're more inclined to grow and less
inclined to actually produce fruit
so a big rule of thumb i think with
pruning fruit trees in general is that
take out the really vigorous lanky
shoots
they usually don't have a ton of fruit
on them anyway so what's the point of
having them
unless you don't have enough
photosynthesis which
is pretty rare so um i'm going to come
in here believe it or not i'm going to
take out
probably all of these turn them back to
maybe
a couple nodes and try to keep all these
branches here
at about the same height same thing over
here
is that way when they're all at the same
height they all have a similar
distinct advantage at achieving
dominance
right we can form a better canopy that
way rather than having one chute that's
just
way above the rest suppressing the
others
preventing a mess in some way
all right let's keep going um i want to
show you guys more of the stone fruits
really quickly i mean if anything i
think
you guys could really use you know a
lesson from this
this video is kind of what not to do you
know some of my trees
knowing this knowing what i know now in
the future they're gonna look
so much better and so much uh different
but
you know these are great examples i
guess of kind of what not to do and i if
i really want if i had a tree like this
this is a pretty good one here actually
this apricot
it's called tomcot it's really one of my
favorites it's so
good but uh it's not exactly pruned here
at my knee
as you can see this is a bit taller
maybe at my
my hip or the top of my thigh but it has
really good branching here at a lower
height
you can see there's one two three four
we got four scaffolds and actually it's
pretty it's forming a nice
vase shape to it um it's got that
umbrella look to it
now there is some more vigorous slanky
shoots over here we can obviously get
rid of
and especially now that i see look
there's all those fruit buds
so wherever the fruit is pretty much can
take all that out
um and it's it's kind of interesting how
these apricots are fruiting
is that they're kind of just fruiting on
the ends and i really had never
uh known that
so it seems like on the tips of the
branches that apricot is really fruiting
and again that's why you don't want to
get too carried away maybe without
seeing
the fruit it seems like these plums are
fruiting here on
spurs and also on the new growth from
last year
it's important to know what the habit of
fruiting is that these trees may have
right like your peaches your nectarines
they're going to fruit on last year's
growth
the cherries are going to fruit let's
say on two or three year old wood
so you really got to be patient and form
a particular
you know situation and some of this
really tall lanky stuff
has just got to go you can see how lanky
all this is even with some summer
pruning
it really wasn't enough i really need to
come in here
and get rid of these very very lanky
shoots
bring them back keep them under control
for the future but
at this point i think if there's fruit
on my trees
considering i'm moving soon
that just is what it is i'll just try to
get as much out of them as i can
and correct the form later but that's
kind of my little lesson here guys
on the uh the pruning of these trees you
know we made a cut
the prior winter right here and then
here's all these new shoots that came up
out of that
and that's because when we do the winter
pruning this is all very vigorous
and it likes to grow and grow and grow
and of course it did
grow and grow and grow and therefore
i really don't even see any fruit on
this tree i'm going to be honest with
you
there's very little fruit because a lot
of this growth is so vigorous
um they're almost like water shoots and
it really didn't serve any purpose
if i would actually had come in here and
let's say
i made my cut here and i did my summer
pruning at about here
all the way across then maybe i would
have actually stopped this tree
from being so vigorous even branching
out a bit more and maybe i would
actually have some more fruit on it
so i know this this takes some time
obviously these are younger trees but
you know um those are some really good
tips guys
i hope that everybody out there is
planting
this is the time as well you're getting
everything together
and uh everybody's staying happy
safe safe and healthy alright so
get out there guys this is the time
we'll see everybody soon alright
take care